[Music]
many say size matters but when it comes
down to business I'm here to tell you
it's all about how you position yourself
and let me tell you why this is great
news for you here's why let's just say
you're the David of your industry going
against Galatasaray ssin and these
people are massive they're sitting on
billions of dollars of assets and you
don't have that type of asset so how do
you compete against them right because a
lot of times I'll talk to entrepreneurs
and they'll say you know what Patrick
you know I have a printing company and I
want to do business cards and I also
want to do magazines and I also want to
do books and I also want to do you know
brochures and I also want to do flip
charts and I also want to do this and I
also want to do banners and also I want
to do everything because I want to be
able to get there's these companies that
do business cards and they make a lot of
money if what if I do all of it right or
a lot of times people will say some of
the financial service I want to do real
estate I want to do loans I want to do
escrow I want to do processing I want to
do underwriting I want to do title I
want to do I want to do it all because
if I do it all I can be so big that
logically may make sense but it's the
dumbest way for someone to position your
position themselves and I'll tell you
and validate on a couple stories why I
got two companies here to give you an
example of one we have Heinz the other
one here we have Howard I'll start off
with Howard some of you may say who is
hallowed I don't even know who hello it
is you who is hallowed let me tell you
who hallow it is hello it is actually
the first company ever to come out with
personal computers now some of you guys
are watching some come on Patrick wasn't
at IBM IBM came out with those big
computers but how is the first one that
came out with the smaller computers this
story is fascinating they came out with
the smaller computers okay they were the
first ones to come out with Mouse Steve
Jobs was the first one to launch Mouse
to the world but he were the first ones
that came out with Mouse they were the
first ones that came out with a small
keyboard it was literally this pic if
you go type in right now online Xerox
Alto and the reason why it's called
Xerox Alto cuz originally was called
Xerox Palo Alto they dropped the Palo
it's called Xerox Alto it came out in
stay with me here in the numbers when
they came out in 1973 they only produced
two thousand of them a thousand for
their employees five hundred for
universities and five hundred they kept
they never marketed this product never
until one day a guy who lives in Palo
Alto calls them and says hey I hear you
guys got this machine that I want to see
and I'm getting ready to start a company
and I'm willing to give you this company
of mine I'll give you a hundred thousand
shares four million dollars I just want
you to allow me to see this machine and
this guy walks into her Lloyd's entire
place in 1978 1979 ish and he walks in
and the guy's looking at says this is a
mouse how come you're not selling this
to the public
do you realize and he gets antsy you
can't control him since I jumping all
over the place they say this guy was so
excited he couldn't even hold himself
together and he said do you guys realize
how powerful how many have you made of
this only 2,000 oh my gosh three days
he's taking notes from morning til night
he's just taking notes taking those he
keeps coming back keeps coming back here
taking those taking those taking those
taking Oaks you know who that guy's bone
Steve Jobs Steve Jobs goes to this place
sees a big dumb company who does not
realize what this computer could be the
PC personal computer if they sold it to
the public they didn't see the vision
they fully didn't see the vision so look
what happens to them Apple takes over
comes out in one day Steve Jobs launches
this Mouse and everybody says disguise
such a visionary he got the mouse from a
hallowed alto product Xerox Alto product
that he saw but he launched it to the
public 2000 computers 1000 for employees
500 for universities 500 they kept Apple
gave it to the world an Apple today is
worth 400 billion dollars now watch what
happens here watch what happens here
few years later 1973 they launched it
eight years later hallowed besides we
should probably consider launching this
computer and they do in 1981 we know for
how much for a hundred thousand dollars
how many people you think in the Florida
$2,000 computer in 1981 think about how
much $100,000 is today $100,000 in
today's dollars like for $500,000 we're
talking a hundred thousand dollars to
buy a piece of computer 1981 so guess
what happens it flops the best thing
Halla we did at that moment they realize
they're way behind the eight-ball way
behind the eight-ball apples taking a
lead on everybody then these other
companies are coming up to compact Atari
you know to all these other companies
are coming up and halides in the back
now hello it has a machine that they
make that's called Xerox and so Xerox
becomes a number one copy machine on
computers Hallowed is ranked number 10
so they said yes we can go compete
versus computers but you know what why
don't we reposition ourselves because
it's about positioning that size how
Lloyd dropped their entire computer
company they lost 84 million dollars
when they just wrote it off you know
what they did they said let's just
position ourself a copy machine we're
not computer companies we compute lis
completely missed out here let's go over
here a big dumb company made a mistake
that we're honest about the fact that
they made a mistake they reposition and
save themselves and Xerox today still it
is a fortune 500 company twenty four
point eight billion dollar company today
they dominate the copy machine
marketplace they dominate the copy
machine marketplace because it
reposition let me come on this side
Hines many many many years ago Hines was
selling pickles they still do today and
they were doing baby food and it was so
focused on baby food and it were so
focused on pickles but they were always
ranked top five in pickles and they were
ranked top five in baby food it was
always Gore Burrell blast sake they just
couldn't beat them you know anything
about pickles you think my blast when
you think about baby food do you think
my Gerber they just couldn't beat those
guys just like man let's go again sighs
these guys are bigger I'm getting tired
I'm David trying to go against Goliath
who's selling all these pickles and
they're selling all this I can't have
tired how do I go against these because
they're killing me huh what are we
number one in we are number one
ketchup what the hell are we thinking
about why don't we just say forget about
this
let's put 5% of our time and resources
into this let's put 95% of our time into
ketchup and so they reposition
themselves and wanted to catch up today
when I think about height and I tell you
Heinz what do you think about do you
think about Heinz pickles come on you
think about Heinz baby but I mean you
know we don't even know how it says baby
food right you think about one thing you
think about ketchup when I tell you see
rocks today do you even think about
halide did you even know that how I
started the first personal computer did
you even know that halide came out with
the first 2,000 pcs that they only use
for themselves in university did you
know I don't know that people didn't
know that now you studies your home like
they missed out but they reposition them
so now let's come back to you now it's
all about you
let's talk to you now you're running a
business what are you selling what are
you trying to sell are you trying to
sell anything and everything everybody's
coming up with I remember when I was
running the business and I was selling
insurance and it was securities at that
time so I'm a serious 766 31:26 life and
health I came from Morgan Stanley so I
started off with stocks and I
transitioned to mutual funds and money
under management then it was very real
universal life policies and venules and
all very well annuities and then I saw
everybody that was fighting for certain
pieces of the pie I want this I want
that I want this and then finally I had
to reposition myself there was a guy in
the valley they were doing mortgages
making $400,000 I'm on path you need to
get into more here just I am this close
this close of getting into mortgages now
a guy you guys got getting in real
estate I'm this close Pat we got to get
into I'm telling you title reps are
making 600 grand a year all you got to
do is drop off some donuts to these loan
officers man it's so easy making 600
granules atado it said nope positioning
no one wants to touch life insurance
nobody wants to touch life injury more
business for us no one everybody wants
to sell very universal life not for us
everybody everybody everybody everybody
nope this is our positioning and we
compete in this positioning today we're
number one in specific products in the
entire world
number one in this one specific product
why positioning positioning positioning
you cannot be everything to everybody
come back to you how many different
products you sell who are you trying to
be what is your main flagship product
you have a flagship product what is your
flagship product what do you sell what
do you mean your marketing what is it
that you got going on are you
positioning it right are you constantly
trying to fight the big guy are you
trying to position yourself to say I'm
going to go against a big guy are you
saying nope I'm going to reposition
myself to grab data smart get because no
one's touching this if you can take an
hour or two listen new years right here
is the first video of value to me you're
watching outside of private motivation
Monday New Year's right here how are you
going to reposition yourself in 17 how
are you going to do it do you have a
plan for what are you going to be you
want to be the big guy of this that's
already run there's 50 of them out there
and you want to compete with this guy
I'm going to reposition yourself it's
almost like saying you going to go into
politics and you're campaigning and
everybody's campaigning around let's
pick something give me a subject on
politics that some people campaign
around let's just say economics let's
just say pro-life pro-choice let's just
say you got military you let you say got
this and it's like you're running for
campaign you're saying I want to build a
wall you know why you say that it's
positioning no one's talking about that
and then all the politicians are saying
what the same old thing and they lose
and they lose some people look you're
value ten minutes your pad how come how
come it's not all the motivation like
some of these other channels all the
time oh you're actually doing how to man
we repositioned ourselves we get out of
heat we get a lot of mail and hate mail
pad we think what you're doing is wrong
what am I doing wrong
you shouldn't give all this content out
for free you should sell it for a few
thousand dollars I'm not doing that
money that's not fair man this is how we
make a living oh I'm losing people to
value tainment I don't care about that
you charge it for free yeah but my
business is getting people to buy my
recordings on webinars and I get them to
pay thousand dollars and if I get a
thousand people to pay for this is how I
make a living I make a living by giving
a content away and I run a real business
now I want to help entrepreneurs around
the world this is our position what's
your positioning by the way we can go
into sports say the same thing we can go
to baseball say the same thing you can
go into Hollywood say the same thing you
can go to basketball church religion
business body building so many different
things as long as you reposition
yourself properly you have an edge if
you're trying to be everybody else you
are constantly going to be fighting in
size and eventually you're comparing
yourself to the wrong person you can't
compete against the size you got to
figure out a way to reposition yourself
and there's a way you could do it in
your business there's a way to do it in
your business but you got to put some
time into it and think about it because
we know we have and you got to
constantly just this what can something
may come back and say well what do you
have to say about Apple Apple went into
computers and they reposition themselves
onto phones because phones are smart yes
because it's called sometimes you got to
call an audible here's our football
work-ready bum bum bum bum audible you
got to do the same you got to do the
same sometimes if Apple realize
everything's going away from computers
were going into tablets what if we make
a phone that's a tablet and it's a smart
phone then they dominate then we have to
change it sad watch I don't know if it's
the watch is it Fitbit it's at this what
is the next thing you have to adapt and
this is why Apple could be the next
video there's a lot of beady C's out
there anybody could be a BDC
how is not the only BDC out there
there's a lot of beady C's out there
okay you just need to figure out a way
to reposition yourself
anyways I can go and talk about the
subject for hours and have a lot of fun
with it but I'll leave it to what it's
at right now what I getting too deep
into it hey it's exciting times this
2017 man time flies just yesterday was
y2k and everybody was trying to set
aside pickle jars and and food and you
know Heinz was making a lot of money
because you were you know all these
things you were setting aside because
all the banks they don't know how to
handle zero in 17 years laters 2017 and
more gray hair for me and if you want to
find out if your agent always look at
this part of your hand this part doesn't
like we all look young here you can tell
your age right here time is flying baby
don't get casual we won't got limited
time to make a big impact in the world
you're part of it as we go out and
revolutionize this entire way of
educating entrepreneurship around the
world which we are just getting started
stay tuned some for some crazy things I
will be launching you're pretty soon
anyways if you haven't subscribed to
value tainment please do so and I don't
really know what you're waiting for we
need your help to sup and click the
alert button as well so you get the
updates every time these videos come out
and if you got any questions any
thoughts about today's video comment on
the bottom I literally go through every
single comment still tilted it's getting
tougher but I still read through every
single comment and I look forward to
seeing your comments take everybody
bye-bye
Oh
[Music]